Russian war games in an area close to
Ukraine these fighter jets are carrying
out constant air patrols Moscow says
there's no link to the events in Ukraine
but the exercises are ratcheting up
tension from the US defense secretary a
word of warning to Russia about its
military exercises I expect Russia to be
transparent about these activities and I
urge them not to take any steps that
could be misinterpreted or lead to
miscalculation during a very delicate
time on the ground in Crimea emotions
are still running high these ethnic
Russians rallying in the regional
capital Simferopol distrust the new
authorities in Kiev earlier armed men
seized the regional Parliament and
chromium and raised the Russian flag
they have so far issued no demands and
their identity was not immediately clear
but witnesses say they spoke Russian
back in Kiev the new government has been
voted in the first task for the
country's newly elected prime minister
is to restore stability as the candidate
chosen for the office of Prime Minister
of Ukraine I want to state that Ukraine
will use all legal and constitutional
means to preserve its territorial
integrity Crimea has been is and will
remain a part of Ukraine with Ukraine's
finances severely strapped Yatsenyuk has
warned his interim government will have
to take unpopular decisions